Judge Judy has just made her political
endorsement for 2024 I know you were all
waiting baited breath drum role plays
Judge Judy is
endorsing Nikki
Haley
yes what' you think I didn't I didn't
really know I assumed she was a little
bit right-wing but not totally
right-wing I don't you know she's a New
Yorker and she said and actually it
makes perfect sense that you would
endorse someone like Nikki Haley why why
is she doing it she said I'm proud to
endorse Nikki Haley because she's whip
smart has executive credentials and was
a superb Governor I truly think she can
restore America and believe she is the
future of this great
nation there are a lot of people like
Judge Judy out there for everyone who
wrote off Nikki Haley early on because
she's more Centrist and
she is more inclined to compromise on
issues that are really near and dear to
conservative so a lot of conservatives
don't really like Nikki Haley there are
a lot of people like Judge Judy out
there
whose political views are maybe not
totally
coherent but they they're still kind of
popular you know these days if you run
in really plugged in political
circles politics is getting a little
more polarized and extreme the
conservatives are becoming more
conservative the leftists are becoming
more
leftist gone are the days of the Bill
Clinton new Democrats gone or the days
of Tony Blair new labor gone or the days
of the social liberal fiscal
conservative which was a a mainstream
way to identify yourself especially in
yepy and urban circles I'm not sure it
ever had a ton of cache ideologically
throughout the rest of the country but
it was popular Bill Clinton got elected
for two to two terms the bushes Bush one
was socially liberal and fiscally
conservative he got elected at least one
time and Bush to was a little more
socially conservative still he gets
elected twice and it that was a that
view which is deeply unsatisfying to
people who are really really plugged
into
politics I think remains fairly popular
still ever since Tony Blair that has
defined the politics of the United
Kingdom even when the the right- wiers
win it's usually on a fiscally
conservative socially liberal platform I
think a lot of people look at that today
they say that's P that kind of view has
led to so many of the problems that we
have today it it's led to all the
economic uh problems that the left
complains about uh the inequality of
wealth and uh the depression of wages
and the Outsourcing of jobs which that's
an issue that the right complains about
but it's also led to all the social
problems that the right complains about
the breakdown of the family the
redefinition of the basic building block
of society all the weird sex stuff it's
so in in some ways this fiscally
conservative socially liberal thing it's
it's the worst of all all political
views and
yet electorally it still seems to have
some power and the 2024 election is
going to
be uh a
bellweather are we moving into a new
political era or does does that view
that really took shape in the
1990s is is that still a holdover does
that the really plugged in political
people the ones who are terminally
online they say there's no way that sort
of thing could work we'll find out were
was the radicalism of Barack Obama and
the the re actionary radicalism of
Donald Trump was that an aberration and
now we're returning back to regular old
clintonian Center left kind of politics
or was it a real break and there's a new
political era Dawning we will see and
Judge Judy will be one of the markers to
see whether or not that is the case the
Jeffrey Epstein Saga gets even more
bizarre they start teasing around New
Year's Eve that there are new
Revelations that are going to come out
about Jeff Epstein new documents to be
unsealed by the courts and I said don't
get your hopes up this is going to be a
big distraction and then I was proven
completely correct about that and all
the news that we got was just stuff we
already heard oh yes Donald Trump knew
Jeffrey Epstein oh yes prince Andrew was
photographed with girls and Jeffrey
Epstein oh yes Bill Clinton likes young
ladies wow shocking stop the
presses the the new information that
came out at least semi- new information
was that one of Epstein's accusers who
said said that she had first or at least
secondhand knowledge of prince
Andrew with these girls of Bill Clinton
of all the big high-profile
clients she said she had tapes that
Jeffrey Epstein recorded these people
that we already knew but she said she
had tapes she had access to the tapes
she' seen them her friend recorded them
whatever she got a hold of
them but that turned out to be fake news
because she made that accusation in 2017
by 2019 she said oh no I made up the
story about having access to the tapes
that wasn't real I just did it to Spook
Jeffrey Epstein so that he wouldn't come
and try to kill me and I also did that
to bring more attention to the epan
story well now she's recanting the
recantation she said yesterday these are
videos that exist the people that know
they exist I'm sure are very frightened
of them being released meaning the guys
like prince
Andrew uh there were apparently hidden
cameras all over Epstein's Island she
said it's no secret that everything was
recorded multiple victims have come
forward confirming my account along with
others I have also seen recordings in
his office she said in the time that I
was with Epstein gillain Maxwell among
others regularly enforced that if I ever
did come forward myself and my family
would be harmed she said she's willing
to testify in court that she has seen
CCTV footage allegedly recorded by
Epstein showing these high-profile
men doing naughty things with her
unnamed friend so now she's saying I
have seen this footage it exists I have
seen it I can testify about it she goes
on when my friend had sexual intercourse
with Clinton Prince Andrew and Richard
Branson sex tapes were in fact filmed on
each separate occasion by
Jeffrey uh thank God she managed to get
a hold of some footage of the filmed sex
tapes which clearly identify the faces
of Clinton Prince Andrew and Branson
having sexual intercourse with her but
she goes on to say frustratingly enough
Epstein was not seen in any the footage
but he was clever like that okay so this
actually is new information we already
knew the tapes existed it would appear
that the FBI when they raided Epstein's
Place took the tapes because a safe went
missing and we we don't have the tapes
and that would be the the evidence that
you'd want to collect so Epstein's not
in it but all these high-profile guys
are okay now the next question is where
are the tapes and this ties in with the
point I made earlier I I actually don't
really care that much I I really don't
want to see Bill Clinton doing anything
naughty on a videotape it's okay I
liveed through the 90s I remember the
stories I don't we all know it happened
I don't need to see it I don't want to
see Prince Andrew or Richard Branson for
that matter either I don't really even
care about the the Epstein Client List
being unmasked I mean it's good it
should be unmasked the people should be
brought to Justice I think that would be
great but what is much more politically
relevant is who Jeffrey Epstein was
working for so the way this plays into
that is someone has those tapes someone
is covering those tapes up whoever is in
possession of those tapes if they are a
law enforcement agency or an
intelligence agency is protecting the
clients of Jeffrey
Epstein we know that gain
Maxwell is the daughter of Robert
Maxwell who is a spy
for maybe three intelligence agencies
Israeli intelligence British
intelligence maybe even Russian
intelligence we know that from British
intelligence actually
we know that Jeffrey
Epstein was very likely connected to
American intelligence because of the
testimony of Alex aasta the US attorney
who prosecuted him in Florida and then
was up for labor secretary under
Trump the next question is where are the
tapes who is holding those
tapes which agency very likely is
holding those tapes why is the agency
holding those tapes what was that
agency's relationship with Jeffrey
Epstein
before he was arrested the first time
before he was arrested the second time
before he totally killed himself and
afterward even if they had no
relationship with Epstein beforehand it
seems unlikely but let's say they didn't
and they just found these tapes why are
they hiding them
now what is that all about if you ask me
that was an excellent clip it was really
good and edifying and entertaining and
educational and really handsome if you
want more of them you've got to ring the
bell and subscribe to my YouTube Channel
right now